[Musique]
pegi 16
marvel avengers est un jeu d'action
aventure à la troisième personne dans
lequel vous incarnerez vos avengers
favori dans une toute nouvelle histoire
l' aventure commence pendant le et des
alors que les avengers inaugurant leur
quartier général sur la côte ouest et
dévoile un tout nouveau réacteurs
alimentés par des cristaux terrigènes
mais après avoir été accusé par le
gouvernement et l'opinion publique
d'être responsable d'un terrible
explosion qui a détruit san francisco
les avengers sont contraints de se
séparer ils sont bientôt remplacée par
une autre organisation l'advanced heidi
mechanics aussi appelé l'aiem qui
affirment vouloir protéger la planète
entière cinq ans plus tard le monde a
bien changé
afin de garantir un meilleur futur grâce
à la science
ayem a remplacé les super héros par des
zinnias simple but d'avancé c'était là
mais peu à peu les signes d'une
conspiration anti héros commence à
apparaître
alors que tous les super héros sont
devenues hors la loi kamal à cannes une
fan des avengers du jersey décident de
prouver l'innocence de ses héros et
d'accepter enfin qui elle est grâce à
son optimisme et à ses pouvoirs
incroyables
kamala entreprend de rassembler les
avengers ce n'est qu'ensemble qu'ils
parviendront à affronter les dangers de
ce nouveau monde
vous commencerez par établir un quartier
général dans un elie porter désaffecté
qui sera remis en état au fil de
l'histoire
vous pouvez personnaliser vos héros pour
jouer en solo ou en ligne avec vos amis
afin de défendre la terre contre les
menaces qui pèsent sur elle chaque héros
possède de nombreuses tenues inspirées
des 80 ans d'histoire de marvel mais
également des tenues inédites
au fil de votre progression vous
débloquerez de nouveaux équipements
combiner différents équipements pour
personnaliser votre style de jeu et
gagner en puissance
améliorer votre équipement en débloquant
des capacités qui influenceront votre
manière de jouer débloquer des
compétences et des aptitudes en gagnant
de l'expérience et adaptez vos héros à
votre style de jeu
grâce au terminal de mission vous avez
la possibilité de participer à des
missions de héros qui sont des aventures
de campagne dans lesquels apparaissent
des super-héros spécifiques et à des
missions warzone jouable en solo ou en
ligne avec un maximum de quatre joueurs
toutes les missions une importance
narrative et la progression de vos héros
est prise en compte dans le reste du jeu
rassembler les plus grands héros de la
terre reformer
les avengers
photos plaisent